record numbers of people are quitting
their jobs it's the so-called great
resignation and it's far from over and a
new report says that our state here in
nevada had the nation's second highest
overall quitting rate in 2021 we were
just behind alaska hector mahia
reporting live this morning hector how
many people were talking about here
well listen to this nevada saw half a
million people quit in all of 2021 a
quick rate of 3.8 percent that's
according to chamber of commerce.org and
this morning we're live on the las vegas
strip because the hospitality and food
service industries ended up having the
highest quit rate in the entire country
so chamber of commerce.org says they
ranked states based on bureau of labor
statistics data we looked it up and they
reported 109 000 job openings in nevada
during november a local expert over at
unlv tells us it's less about quitting
and more about workers reevaluating
their economic choices business and
economic expert andrew woods points out
it's not just the hospitality industry
health care workers are also feeling a
sense of burnout too
i think a lot of that is they have been
through
uh
what some people have described as war
when you're working in these er rooms
with covet and they've seen a lot and
they want a different
they want a different job
so a lot of people say they're leaving
their jobs for a number of reasons
better pay flexibility benefits we also
want better treatment at work wood says
the pandemic gave people a lot of time
to rethink what they actually want out
of their job particularly those in
customer facing or front line industries
and a large number of people are also
retiring which is also contributing to
the job openings we'll go into that
still ahead at 6 30. reporting live
hector mejia live local now